[Music]
I'm Eddie whoo and I'm head teacher of
mathematics at cherrybrook Technology
High School applying for the
Commonwealth mate teaching Awards was
really about helping people in broader
society understand that we have people
working in schools who are dedicated
skilled and pour their lives into
improving the learning outcomes for
young people and building their
communities it's been great having the
Commonwealth Bank and schools Plus come
together to really put all kinds of
support underneath programs that we
already knew we're successful but we
always struggle to find the resources to
really amplify them and make them as
effective as they are across a broad
population so for instance one of the
programs that we've been running is
called mass pass it stands for peer
assisted study sessions in mathematics
we took year 11 students we pair them up
with a year seven or eight buddy and we
tried this out as a little project on
the side a couple of years ago we
realized it was really successful but we
were always just running it on the side
with the support that we've been able to
gain through the column with my Teaching
Fellowship has enabled us to be able to
pour extra staff and students into
making that a really integrate a part of
how students learn mathematics and
develop in their confidence it's a
little bit strange trying to talk about
your own achievements and highlighting
that but it was a wonderful process to
reflect on all the things that I've been
able to contribute to and be a part of
the teams that I've been able to work
with and the way that that's made a
difference for students and that's been
an opportunity that has been amazing and
I love doing that every day
you
[Music]